days after part of a door blew out of a
Boeing airliner investigators make a
discovery I'm excited to announce that
we found the door plug this picture
prompted a local teacher to reach out
after he found the aircraft's missing
part in his garden and it's considered
crucial to discovering why this happened
in mid-flight yes we are emergency we
are depressurized but we do need to
return back too we have 177 passengers
still is
188 the drama unfolded on Friday after
Alaska Airlines flight 1282 suffered a
blowout after taking off from the city
of Portland in Oregon an external door
plug which blew off in a section of the
fuselage at an altitude of 5,000 m many
passengers were scared they would be
sucked out of the cabin we just heard
like a loud thing I looked at my left
and there's just this huge like gaping
hole first I thought it was the
emergency door but there was no door
there it was just like a part of the
wall that flew off the plane carrying
177 passengers and crew made a safety
emergency landing back in Portland the
aircraft had only been in service for a
few months and is now being inspected a
cockpit voice recording considered
crucial for the investigation was found
to have been overwritten and its data
could not be retrieved an inquiry found
Pilots had reported warning alert
days before the incident in these three
previous flights after the light
illuminated uh they flipped the switch
to alt mode uh which is normal there's a
backup it was very
benign uh nothing occurred very benign
the light illuminated they flipped it
they reported it it was tested uh by
maintenance and then
reset Alaska Airlines has grounded its
Fleet of 65 max9 aircraft as a pre-call
caution a total of 171 Jets of the same
model remain grounded pending further
safety inspections Axel zovich Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer